un dernier panier de bamba cei à 12
secondes de la fin du match face à paris
14 et l'entente le chesnay-versailles
peut jubiler
le fcv 78 réussi à éviter une revente à
d'assaut samedi 18 mai sur son tas en
quarts de finale de prénationale
vainqueur 73 à 52 à l'aller les hommes
de la cité royale se sont imposés au
retour 81 à 71 sur leur parquet il
fallait être concentré respecté les
consignes et jouer au basket voilà tous
les matches il faut gagner
non même si l'on était à + 21 h 30 donc
j'écris c'était de gagner l'objectif
c'était véritablement de jouer pour
gagner et surtout pas de jouer pour ne
pas perdre et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
du coup ça a fait un match plein voilà
ils se sont défendus avec leurs armes et
on a encore été plus fort ce soir donc
c'est amplement mérité je pense avec ce
résultat l'entente le chesnay versailles
78 se qualifie pour le final four de la
division l'équipe affrontera meudon demi
finale sur terrain neutre à palaiseau
pour une revanche les veut donner les
avait battus au mois de février dernier
en cas de victoire les joueurs de la
cité royale se verrait propulsé en
nationale 3 rien n'est acquis à part une
place en demi finale
tout reste à faire et on va jouer notre
saison maintenant non plus sur x match
là il en reste plus que 2 donc or on le
sait et il va falloir faire le job
bien évidemment ce groupe a le niveau
parce que je sais qu'on aura du coeur et
on le montrera les versailles et auront
deux semaines complètes pour préparer au
mieux ce week-end décisif la
récupération devrait être plus simple
après cette victoire
[Applaudissements]
à